[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you stand sometime
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
introducing the outriders broadcast a
monthly show where you're going to see
new areas new enemies new guns and here
and all new features and details on this
dirty and desperate side by epic
premiering Thursday the 28th of May
[Music]
we awoke from one nightmare into another
not on our dying earth but somewhere
much worse
good guy good guy
I came to Enoch as our last chance the
chance at a new home but what we found
doesn't save humanity it concerned
we awoke changed the anomaly Unleashed
within us burnings power impossible
power
[Music]
Enoch robs us of our humanity yet gives
us so much more each step taking us
further from what we were and closer
to what we must become
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we came to Enoch looking for hope a
fresh start on an untouched planet
then we found the singer so we set out
to discover its
that was our first encounter with
anomaly
when the storm struck the outriders were
forced back into cryo sleep while we
slept
anomaly greater and the creatures that
we have advanced
thirty years later when we finally woke
the world had changed but so I
[Music]
with our advanced technology rendered
useless by the anomaly a successful
colonization wasn't possible
[Music]
and after all these years the signal is
still out there
and at its source a chance to find
answers
start again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we venture across scenic we discover a
violent new world while we slept those
that survived the anomaly did what they
could to carve out a living and
something resembling society took shape
we scavenge for weapons and honor and
trade what little resources we have in
order to give ourselves a fighting
chance of survival engineer vehicles
from scrap and set out towards the
horizon
and as we push farther into the unknown
our powers grow
our knowledge of how to use them
[Applause]
but as we start to understand our power
we discover there are others
was paid a heavier price
[Music]
[Music]
many threats stand between us and the
source of the signal those of us who
survived exposure to the anomaly
move beyond our physical limits we've
become altered as pyromancers we
manipulate explosive volcanic energy and
devastating walls of flame
as tricksters we manipulate the fabric
of time-space
to take out enemies by
devastators we shatter the earth
a brute-force powered by the planet
itself
and so our journey across Enoch begins
discover what lies at the heart of the
signal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we came to Enoch as our last chance a
chance at a new home but what we found
didn't save humanity it can see that we
woke changed burning with power
impossible power each step taking us
further from what we were and closer
to what we must become
[Music]
hello my name is Lucy and welcome to the
first in a new monthly show called the
outriders broadcast outrageous is a big
game with a heck of a lot to share and
talk about and the broadcast is going to
pack all of our upcoming announcements
information gameplay and trailers into a
monthly hit beamed straight to you we
went wide with the reveal back in
February and showed you a lot of what
the game has to offer
we put the first three hours into the
hands of press and media and the initial
reaction to that demo was incredible
honestly though you've only really just
in the tip of the iceberg so far since
then we've had a lot of questions and
comments about specifics of the game and
this episode is a great opportunity to
reflect on that expose some more of the
depth around the features that we've
shown you so far and show you some brand
new stuff too today we're premiering
some fresh gameplay as we take a look at
the first city with details on law UI
and world tears being surfaced along the
way this is still set in the human
colony of Enoch before the outriders
have set off on their epic journey
across the planets in order to find the
mysterious signal for this part of the
broadcast
I'll let spend from square-enix external
studios do the talking hi in this
episode's playthrough we're taking you
to the first city it's the first human
colony in Enoch
established by the ECA shortly after
their arrival the huge structure in the
background is actually one of the
engines of the SM Flora's the massive
spaceship you and the rest of humanity
used to travel from earth to Enoch it
was brought down to the surface of the
planet to serve as a temporary power
source for the colony but when the first
big anomaly storm hit the first city the
engine was damaged and at the risk of a
meltdown and after a few months of
initial panic and chaos that's exactly
what happened
the engines nuclear reactor exploded
blanketing many areas with heavy
radiation with the city having lost its
main source of energy and most of the
water and food - coming unsafe to
consume many perished in the aftermath
after the anomaly storms riots and
decades of war both in a city in the
slums surrounding it have long been
abandoned by the authority and most of
its inhabitants
this is hostile territory now and they
have them roam around trying to scavenge
for scraps while navigating through
pockets of radiation and monster nests
our mission here is to find and obtain
an old truck which belongs to an
important ECA scientists called CED CED
claims something on this truck holds
invaluable information about the anomaly
and a mysterious signal for now we only
face humanoid enemies on our path but
first city will introduce us to a new
fret the before Oh like most of the
monstrous creatures seen on Enoch the
before was a pre-existing species that
rapidly evolved by the corruption of the
anomaly and it was one of the first
hostile creatures that attacked the
colony in its early years one thing is
certain though their strength is in
numbers even a battle-hardened outriders
often left if only one option when
facing the swarm run let's join our
Pyromancer Nova and see what she's up to
on her mission to find Cindy's truck
yeah like I said sometimes you just need
to run
but not for long
let's take a quick moment to talk about
a pretty important feature UI we know
that screen real estate is important to
hit the fence
there's a lot of information that needs
to be delivered and plants at various
preferences in terms of the hierarchy of
information we're conscious of different
people want different things from an RPG
shooter some people like seeing
everything from damage numbers quest
trekkers to life bars and more while
others might want a more pure shooter
experience everyone falls in different
places on that spectrum so we made sure
to include options to customize your UI
experience whatever you like let's see
if I can clear up my screen a bit I
really want to take in the view today so
I'm changing my heart to a more minimal
shooter style UI let's return to our
Pyromancer Nova now she made good
progress through the runes of first city
and is now heading towards a giant
drawbridge
by the way before will come in different
shapes and sizes
son of a--
thank you but let's take a moment to
talk about dynamic difficulty settings
in outriders our brightest has a
flexible difficulty system called
Welters that allows you to fine-tune
your difficulty setting at your leisure
this means that the game will
organically find the right challenging
difficulty for you even if you're a
skilled and maxed out player absolutely
chewing through the battlefield with
fully optimized gear I did behind
Walters is that you can make outriders
either a just here for the story game or
a true Hal on enoch experience it is
totally up to you generally speaking the
higher world tears are more difficult as
they increase enemy stats such as
damaged armor health and enemy level
however you will also gain more rewards
get better loot drops and unlock more
accolades you'll start our work they've
won and scale up as you play the game
depending on your performance when you
eventually get up to the higher world
tiers you will get to a point where you
will need to optimize your gear and
build accordingly in order to continue
to progress let's pull up the world tier
menu here and have a closer look as you
can see world tiers can be manually
adjusted on the fly depending on how
you're currently doing you'll gain
experience in combat towards unlocking
them next well tear should you be
playing on the highest world tier
possible for your character this
experience is separate from the
character level but is accumulated much
in the same way
experience from quests doesn't
contribute to welter experience that
quest combat does
here's the kicker bow whenever you die
you will lose a percentage of world tare
advancement this prevents you from
accidentally stepping up to even more
difficult world tears should you be
struggling on the current one you really
need to earn your Spurs here each newly
unlocked world save will also reward you
with either a resource or a new rare
epic or legendary weapon and in some
cases both payer world tears will enable
loot to drop that is actually of a
higher level than the player themselves
this starts act world tier 4 and scales
till world tier 15 at the same time
playing on these same will tears will
allow the player to wear gear that is
higher than their level while they are
in that world tier 1 final notes on
difficulty the difficulty of the game
and enemies will also be impacted by the
amount of players in the game this will
ensure that the game remains challenging
while playing in groups with friends but
it isn't punishing to the point of not
being fun when playing solo for now
things were a little on the easy side
for his back there
so let's crank things up a gear thanks
Lucy Nova likes Ernie stuff so yeah
bring it on one of the things we've been
super mindful of gearing development is
how all that background and exposition
is delivered Queen held at one of the
pains of this genre is having to work to
consume story we don't want our lower to
be a chore or an obstacle to immersion
so we've ensured that everything is on
the disc and in the game itself
what exploration in talking to NPCs will
deliver additional context in background
files backstories and law are unlocked
as you play and can then be pulled from
the menu at any time so say for example
you want to learn about the first city
and initial colonization of Enoch you
can check it out right here
the next section will be pretty tough
so ask my friends and community manager
Robby to take along four little co-op
action he's sporting a badass trickster
in a complete legendary gear set now
let's do some real damage we have a
truck to find
[Music]
in the interest of timing to keep some
surprises for you we're going to skip
ahead a little now let's join the final
minutes of the brutal finale against a
portal wielding Cathy
and then we have it the captain left us
a nice piece of armor and yeah a couple
of limbs - we hope you enjoyed our
little trip to first city and I see you
in the next episode stay safe out there
and that is it for the playthrough
section of this broadcast we'll be
showcasing new areas and features in
future episodes next up we are
premiering a series of videos that we
like to call spotlights
these are in-depth features that expose
the depth around a particular aspect of
the game and today we are looking at the
first of three currently announced
classes the trickster
let's take a look greetings outriders
welcome to the outriders spotlight a
collection of videos where you can find
out much more about individual topics in
the world of outriders this is your
one-stop shop
that's place to be where you'll have
explanations straight from the team
behind the game this is just the start
we'll have plenty of deep dives coming
in the future to prepare you for landing
on Enoch so subscribe to our YouTube
channel and you'll never miss a beat
we're kicking things off with one of the
four classes you'll be playing as the
trickster
sit back and learn everything you need
to know about ding assassin class as
tricksters we manipulate
fabric of time and space to take our
enemies by surprise
who is this class ball players who like
to get in and out quick
leaving devastation in your wake
tricksters are for you however because
of the waste skills and your passives
can be customized certain builds of the
trickster could be used as a tank role
for the rest of your group the choice is
yours
fundamentals the trickster is focused
around space and time powers and effects
you can see this in the clutters melee
attack which stuns and slows and moves
hit by it oh and speaking of Meli it
isn't one size fits all not only did the
different classes have melee abilities
enhanced by their own unique powers
there are two variations as well it's
got your standard melee when standing
still all your upgrades it attack when
you activate melee while sprinting
healing within the brutal and violent
world of outriders they'll come times
where you'll be hurt and need to be
heals the key thing to note here is that
there aren't any quick fix health
potions or magic spells but playing the
ffensive LY restores HP instead this
affects your play style in that it
invites you to play more aggressively
rather than running duck for cover when
your health is low your best chance at
survival may actually be to teleport to
where the fighting is thickest taking
your enemies down is the key to keeping
you alive unique to the trickster they
get healed when killing enemies in close
range and they also get shields while
other classes have their own healing
mechanics
let's explore four out of eight total
powers the trickster has at their
fingertips each class has eight powers
in total you'll start off with a single
power and unlock more as you level up
the tricks that will feature an
additional four powers on top of those
that we're talking about today but we'll
showcase these later on how will one
temporal slice this will be the very
first power you unlock as a trickster
and it's the class's bread and butter
all enemies hit by the slash will be
temporarily paralyzed which is displayed
by their skeletons becoming visible and
their movement greatly slowing down
slowing enemies down is a key trickster
skill as it allows you and your squad
mates to play it into any enemies caught
in the effects the temporal slice is
especially effective in combination with
other skills that cluster enemies close
together the slice will affect all
enemies and allow for maximum damage and
kills which can easily heal a nearly
dead trickster back to full health
thanks to the mechanics power to
borrowed time upon use of this skill you
will instantly gain a percentage of your
maximum health as a shield that absorbs
damage before your health is affected
additionally using the power will create
a time clone of yourself in the location
that the power was used
you can thereafter freely move about and
engage the enemy I'll set up a trap but
using the borrowed time again when your
time clone is still active
well teleport you back to the time
clones location should you be going into
a high-risk combat situation you may
want to use this skill as your quick
escape from danger just when you're
about to die you can teleport to safety
power three slow trap this power will
create a dome around you that slows down
enemies and enemy projectiles while
still allowing yourself and your allies
to move at normal speed think of it as
your own personal bullet time bubble
this is a skill that can be used both
offensively and defensively defensive
activate the dome in the middle of a
firefights and you and your fellow out
riders will be able to sidestep any
incoming projectiles or melee attackers
you can also use the slow trap to help
in resurrecting a fellow teammates if
they've been downed in a particular
hotspot Enoch is also home to many
different kinds of enemies and may
occasionally find yourself swarmed by
melee attackers or monsters activating
slow trap in these circumstances can be
an excellent way to trap numerous
enemies move into a cluster of enemies
and activate the dome to make them all
move in slow motion then go to town
power for hug the fray when activated
this skill will allow you to highlight
any visible enemy using the skill once
more will teleport you directly behind
them and you will additionally gain a
percentage of your maximum health as a
shield whilst also slowing the enemy
it's used on you can instantly walk
across the battlefield to either get
yourself into or out of trouble this
skill could even be your opening gambit
when first entering a combat encounter
you can walk right into the thick of the
enemies and lay waste around you
alternatively you can also use it to
teleport single enemies who are separate
from the main body of attackers this
should buy you some time
allow you to pick enemies off one by one
as with all classes and outriders powers
can be hot swat as long as they're not
on cooldown
you could even change them while in
combat
we'd recommend taking cover to do so or
you may find yourself dead powers and
outriders are designed to have
relatively short cooldowns there's
essentially no limit to how much you can
use them to get the most out of combat
so far we've mainly looked at full
powers in isolation but outriders truly
comes together when you and your squad
mates are in a thick of battle timing
your powers perfectly to inflict maximum
carnage how the prey can be especially
effective when combined with borrowed
time teleport into the thick of it using
hunter prey then inflict maximum damage
using temporal slice or slow trap if
running into danger or owed time can be
your grip cord to get you out of it
again while from the praise on Calder
this is only a very simple example of
how powers could be chained you'll no
doubt find your own most effective ways
of playing out riders your way also your
trickster each class is a tree of class
point notes that you can activate to
alter the way your build and skills work
class points are acquired by leveling up
you won't be able to fill out the entire
class tree but you will be able to
respec your nose to change the way you
play the three branches for the tricks
they're linking to the class's
fundamentals movements damage and
disruption with each branch providing
both major and minor passives in the
tricksters case these three branches are
called master of space harbinger and
assassin there are elements of the
fundamentals in all branches they're
intertwined and you can cross link them
to your personal needs and wishes
Durov space branch will generally
provide bonuses while the player is
moving and improve to your close combat
effectiveness note air will enhance your
damage with shotguns and SMGs when you
use movement based skills
the Harbinger is the tank path of the
trickster this part focuses on providing
damage mitigation as well as shield
bonuses to provide maximum survivability
and the assassin branch focuses on skill
damage outputs several nodes here
provide bonuses when you use damage and
movement skills and the path provides
additional anomaly power and skill each
options
additionally the equipment you use may
impact the way your skills work and
equipments passives might reduce the
cooldown or duration of a skill all they
mates all turrets on a more vital level
but will showcase these in the future so
we are approaching the end of the
outriders broadcast but before we close
out we wanted to sum is from you guys in
a section where depressin their
quickfire Q&A rounds and we'll be doing
this at the end of each broadcast going
forward so keep those questions coming
in for this part of the show I'm gonna
hand the reins back over to Robby
outriders community manager and general
fountain of knowledge for all things
outriders as he answers your questions
directly thanks Lucy all right let's do
this
five quick questions five quick answers
question what is outriders games as a
service this is one of our most commonly
asked questions so to be 100% clear no
outriders is not games as a service and
will be a complete experience out of the
box question 2 what passive outriders is
the team currently working on what we
showed you in February is a very early
section of outriders we are currently
focusing on improving polishing
debugging and balancing the entire game
the resolve this work may mean that some
of the animations as well as the
functionality of the game may be changed
and improved between now and the
writers final release question 3 will
outriders feature microtransactions this
is an easy one
no outriders will not feature
microtransactions question 4 will apt
writers use de nouveaux so we know this
is a hot topic in certain parts of the
community again nice and simple answer
no it will not have de nouveaux question
5 of the gameplay revealed so far what
parts of outriders was shown the
gameplay revealed so far features
content only from the first few hours of
the campaign throughout your travels
across enoch you will encounter a great
diversity in environments and colorful
surroundings so what you've seen so far
the game is really just the immediate
area in which the outriders wake up in
Enochs is a big place you'll be seeing
much more of these areas in the coming
months so stay tuned for that as always
be sure to send your questions to us on
social media and be sure to use the
hashtag outriders and keep it up Robbie
we'll be putting a call up for questions
for the next broadcasts out very soon so
keep your peepers peeled all that and
this concludes our first-ever outriders
broadcast thank you so much for watching
and next time we'll be taking a look at
the journey into the unknown plus the
characters joining your adventure as you
battle through a hostile world
I'm seeing some really strange [ __ ] down
here will also be showcasing a brand new
area and delving deeper into our next
class the Pyromancer science stuff until
then thank you so much for watching
again guys and we will see you next time
you
you